non sa proprio dove andare
il rischio
[Musica]
ragazzi sono dentro la caviamo seguire i
simboli delle streghe per trovare le
streghe
benvenuti risalita st rinforzi nuova
challenge nascondino del tuo colore
pauroso in montagna perché oggi faremo
un'escursione in montagna e il percorso
delle streghe lascia sempre vi piace se
volete video paurosi altri nascondigli
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
iniziamo subito la tollera ciao ragazzi
abbiamo viaggiato da riva del garda in
macchina e ora siamo a castelrotto in
provincia di bolzano
sull'alpe di siusi spero che sto
pronunciando il tutto bene è stupendo
quasi siamo emozionati tantissimo nelle
strade perché se arriva un sacco in alto
comunque mi faccio un piccolo rom tour e
poi vi faccio vedere il paesaggio fuori
siamo in un hotel che si chiama paradiso
cure living ed è stupendo un momento
buon pro tour
allora qual è il c'è una cosa
stranissima e bagno
bagno finissimo e tutto di pietra
guardate che bello il lavandino bianco e
nero praticamente ho notato una cosa
stranissima in bagno se ci sono dei
pulsanti e penso che il bagno sia come
quello giapponese so che potranno farvi
vedere un gabinetto in un hotel fermo
per date questa cosa
allora qual è il letto di maletto e poi
la parte più bella in assoluto è questo
balcone che è una vista spettacolare
vendite
parete che bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ok tocca a me nascondermi giusy rotili è
il colore che io scelgo e il blu pronti
via allora ho deciso di mandare a
nascondermi lazio guarda te c'è una
lumaca scan questo appello in cui stiamo
è ricoperto da rumor che gigante blu
che i ragazzi sono nascosta dietro alla
lumaca gigantesca blu vediamo se
l'italia riuscirà altro corpo
[Musica]
natale è laggiù vedete non penso che mi
vedrà fa o no forse mi ha vista pure
possibile che mi ha già trovato ha
definitivamente
che tende blu e chi c'è qua
[Musica]
ok ora tocca a vitale nasconderti che
colore scegli fai vedere scelgo il tuo
colore preferito il verde ma come faccio
a trovarti in mezzo al verde quasi tutto
verde complimenti e va bene vai a
nasconderlo le io aspetto poi controllo
fino a 60 voti
[Musica]
trovato
quello che una sponda di un centro al
vero parola appunto per me e ora
prosegue o ragazze stiamo percorrendo un
percorso in montagna e si chiama le
sorgenti delle streghe ed è un po molto
inquietante
abbiamo già trovato una cosa molto
strana che forse un tempo era una strega
guardando riuscite a vedere la faccia ma
evitano i non gliene frega niente perché
lui vorrebbe mangiarsi i funghi
guardate qui puliga reti che belli un
fungo e giallo enorme
[Musica]
non li puoi mangiare sono velenosi
potrebbero estre velenose potresti anche
morire quindi in buffa
non è giusto puro ma proseguiamo magari
troviamo altro da mangiare a un po paura
ma provo a toccarla
milano
[Musica]
questo percorso si chiama le sorgenti
delle streghe perché alla fine si sono
le sorgenti sulfuree delle streghe ma
ora tocca a evitare nasconderti che
colori se gli scelgo il mio colore più
antipatico il marrone ma è tutto marrone
con certi marrone verde e va bene allora
vai a nasconderti
e io dovrò cercare ok ciao bastato
idonea
[Applauso]
sorpresa
la casetta non roma in cui l'altra
veri
per capire
basta solo che qui abbiamo la cassetta
marrone sull'albero un pool c
l'ascoltiamo proprio qui nella casetta
sull'albero
vediamo se riusciamo a vedere anita ma
facciamoci alla finestra
non è andata non la vedo sì secondo
scorsi talmente fatto bene che ci siamo
persi sa dove andare
chissà questa è un'altra
alice scende
non sa proprio dove andare
[Musica]
o no sta proprio qui ecco la nota mi ci
nascondiamo adesso non ci possiamo lo
scopo
[Musica]
ci siamo la porta nascondiamoci dietro
questa dove tronco dell'albero qua
[Musica]
nessuno sembrava qualcuno
per me tu mi faccio se io posso farlo
state giusto paura delle altezze il
colpo mi rispondono nascosto ora se
andiamo subito ragazzi che cos'è questo
secondo voi sembra qualcosa che le
streghe hanno lasciato per fare qualche
stregoneria un pendolo
non so cosa serva però
[Musica]
attraversiamo il ponticello con la
cascata adesso
came nasconderlo scelgo il colore nero
giro se non guardare conta fino a 60
andiamo nascondersi dentro questa cappa
nera che dentro e nera
[Musica]
ragazzi sono dentro la capanna ma è
tutto buio un po di paura
[Musica]
ok ragazzi sono al buio dentro la
capanna spero che è vitale non mi
troverà qua ma fa molta paura qua dentro
sono uscita dalla capanna perché il
tempo è scaduto e vitale non mia trova
hai perso mi mettevo non mi trovato ero
dentro alla capanna che ha molto
inquietante c'era tanto buio e droghe
rimasti subito ma non mi hai trovato
perché all'interno la capanna era nero e
almeno vinto questo tour
la cassiera dobbiamo attraversare due
ponticelli questo è basso non è un
problema ma l'altro è un po più alto dai
queste pagine è stelle altre volte
l'unità paurissima dei conti di legno
[Applauso]
brasile
fuori porta
sono ben intonata
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sani e salvi
ho attraversato
vabbè
caro beppe rumore ecco il simbolo delle
streghe dobbiamo seguire i simboli delle
streghe per trovare le streghe andiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
guarda questo ponte stregato
continuiamo la nostra avventura presto
questi percorsi creati dalle streghe
andiamo
ci sono delle frecce qua vuol dire che
siamo sulla strada giusta
una strega sicuramente è passata di qua
guardate quell'albero
siamo arrivati finalmente la sorgente di
zolfo guardate andiamo a vedere come e
dobbiamo bere l'acqua di zolfo e dicono
che abbia proprietà magiche ma solo
questa è voi non vedete la casa e solo
questa delle streghe andiamo speriamo di
non trasformarsi in un fungo in un
folletto uno spot o il luglio di quei
tronchi degli alberi
ok ragazzi ci siamo ecco qua l'acqua ha
soccorso all acqua sulfurea delle
streghe beviamo la vediamo come che
apporta e freddissima ma si sta
trasformando da di uovo sodo e
trasformando in un rombo dopo l'acqua
delle streghe ha davvero un sapore di
riposo di uovo sodo però dicono che sia
magica e che faccia molto bene alla
pelle comunque avremmo dovuto guardare
meglio il cartello per chi guarda c'è
proprio l'immagine dell'uomo anche se
non capisco niente di quello che c'è
scritto john in all the broom man un dio
guarda
un'altra prova magica delle streghe sono
tre pietre lordi potrebbe caderci
addosso si ha paura si parecchio altro
perché sono molto pesanti
se ti chiedono addosso
a far superare la prova delle streghe ma
non è che mi cadono sulla pancia per non
posso più mangiare non hai paura che
cadono la strega che qui sta analizzando
il cervello quindi che sta muovendo la
strega si cervello e pancia stato
memorizzato tutti i dati ora vorrei un
incantesimo dotto potrò mangiare senza
ingrassare no hai superato dopo l'ultima
prova della strada e adesso sì che posso
farcela maggiore tutto paura aspettando
che la strega vada via
quando smette di muoversi la spiegazione
è andata ok
sono libera dall'incantesimo abbiamo
fatto a pezzi una casetta
chi ci sarà qua dentro casa non aprirà
c'è una strega miniatura là dentro
sicuramente no ho paura
cosa non lo so ma è meglio che ci
allontaniamo il più presto possibile i
cattivi ecco nuovamente il simbolo delle
streghe sono passate anche di qua
il tuo vitale
o non avrebbe preso le streghe
[Musica]
insomma la scadenza mai prima di allora
dovevo portare fino a 70 quindi questo
turno non vale così il trono dello
stregone guarda e quello
il trono della strega ci sono dei piedi
qua
[Musica]
ragazzi lo strike e l'abbiamo trovata
quest'altro lazio un mezzo all'altro ed
alberi
andiamo
la strega è stata pietrificata quali
dell'albero siamo riusciti a trovarla
speriamo che non ci mandi qualche
stregoneria qualche maledizione
ciao frega ragazzi grazie di questo
percorso
[Musica]